i was wondering what you thought about
one of my cases uh
first essex bank heist yes i read that
one they got robbed the day before their
grand opening i never solved that one
that bothered me for 20 years but i see
that you wrote a note here that says
contractor did it comma so obvious oh
what
well you know us millennials were always
exaggerating but what i think happened
there is is that i was reading that file
and i noticed that the contractor russo
was the um
obvious obvious suspect but only in the
sense that he was the only one who could
have possibly done it because he had the
blueprint
i talked to russo he had an alibi of
course of course
but you know the name of the company was
russo and son so
faker probably maybe definitely the suns
did it maybe
probably for sure what's going on oh
nothing just had a real eye-opening
conversation with your dad
i wanted his approval but he says i'll
never be good enough for you what the
hell
i know right tell him he's wrong no i'm
upset with you
that's right go get him tiger i'm also
upset with you
what is this 1950 i can't date someone
unless i have my father's approval
oh obviously you can you guys act like
this is your decision to make
like the woman doesn't even exist in
this equation well this woman
wait amy shut up excuse me i mean i'm so
sorry you were making a totally valid
point about gender equality but i just
thought of something really important so
i'm gonna hang up on you okay love you
bye
it wasn't russo or his sons it was a
daughter
well well well he finally did it died
horribly
escaped just like he said he would all
those years ago
i'll be coming back for you i'm just
like disco baby
i will never die true disco will never
die
but you will all right the state police
is deploying 30 men and four helicopters
to comb the area of the accident i felt
comfortable saying
this disco man has danced his last
disco dance sir it's fun to see you
breaking out the old lingo but do you
think you're jumping the gun
all the evidence points to the strangler
being dead not all the evidence
right the random piece of thread you
think is a yo-yo string it is a yo-yo
string the most dangerous part of the
yo-yo it just feels like you're trying
to relive your glory days
absurd what do you have in that box over
there well memories and keepsakes of my
greatest cases mm-hmm to remind me
of the strangler's mo he always seduced
an accomplice into doing his fiendish
bidding
i bet it was the van driver you mean the
woman who was thrown violently from the
vehicle and just barely survived yeah
i'm sure she was very
badly injured sorry if my voice is raspy
they just took the breathing tube out
but they left a bs in
good god so miss park it says in my file
that you drove mr zumowski on multiple
occasions
yes because he had to go to the hospital
a lot he was very very old she's clearly
been seduced she has
let's cut the crap you helped him escape
you planted a cadaver in the back you
flip the van
on purpose then the strangler set it on
fire and sprinkle some of his hair
nearby so there'd be a dna match
then he left behind his calling card
this yo-yo
string that's not a yo-yo string that's
part of the lanyard we give to the older
inmates when they become fall risks
you're lying you've succumbed to his
groovy voodoo sir
i don't think she's lying look at this
photo from the file oh my goodness
so this string is just a string
the dna was really a match the disco
strangler is actually dead
and that chapter of my life is forever
closed
well that's fantastic news
sir you haven't come out of your office
in a while how you doing
terrible you were right i was trying to
relive my glory years
but the fact remains they are behind me
my only nemesis now
father time come on sir that's
ridiculous
you're on the cutting edge in fact
you're so progressive they were scared
to make you police commissioner you're
as modern as they come
what is that noise it's my fax machine
oh captain
sally i'm young what is it it's an
aerial photograph from one of the
helicopters i had deployed
take a gander boys it's him the disco
strangler
oh my god you were right of course i was
i know him better than anyone we're
two sides of the same coin you've told
us this story many times and you'll
hear it again only thing those bullies
have over you
is that you never solved that case so
why don't we solve it together
how are we gonna do that we'll sneak
into the 6'5 steal that old case file
and work it until we find your burglar
then we march back into that precinct
and we grind these kittens up and shove
them down their throat
yes don't listen to him you're a part of
something much bigger than yourselves
what up jake why are these dicks out of
their cage i stayed up all night working
on your case
and hans john and nakatomi made for
great company
i gave them all die hard names i don't
understand why you wasted another night
on a case no one's ever gonna solve
sarge i am way too sleep deprived to
deal with your negativity right now
let me show you what i did i started off
by making a map of all of the burglaries
that have gone down in brooklyn since
1996 to see if there was a pattern
that led me to this
there is so much crime in new york no
one should live here
anyways i tripped out on that for a
couple hours but i got cheered up
after i took a picture of the kitties
messing around in my little hoodie i'll
show it to you later so basically you
wasted a whole night no no no my friend
no no no cause then i dove back into
your file and found
this cool the low point my entire life
sarge
this photo was taken in 1996. you told
me your guy broke his spine
two years before that so 94 check out
his sneakers
95 jordans they came out a year after
the accident
look at the souls they're all muddy
which means that son of a [ __ ] can walk
bingo hey there
remember me
[Music]
so this is weird oh no you don't circle
strap
i knew it you could walk the whole time
i was right about the catacombs too huh
now where's the cat
been 20 years sarge cat's probably dead
i'm still bringing him in
[Music]
kablamo scrubs i nailed it i solved
captain holt's brain teaser and found
the location of our secret meeting the
answer
the broom closet in your face and who's
face now yours
gina and i have been here 20 minutes
though my presence is not puzzle-related
i just followed terry into a dark closet
hey you saw the puzzle before me
nerds they solved it first they're the
nurse i'm cool like you
wait where's captain holt where's amy
yeah she should be the first one here
doesn't she go to like an adult puzzle
camp every summer
yes but please don't bring that up i've
been throwing out her mailers guys
if those two aren't here i'm thinking we
must be in the wrong place
no trust me we're definitely in the
right place i'm 100 sure about this
oh i guess just solve the puzzle we did
oh we did yeah we're in the wrong place
i told you not to lie
what were you thinking i thought it
would work and i wanted to be the one
that got him is this about your ego
are you that desperate for everyone to
know how great you are it's not about
everyone
okay it's just i wanted you to know
oh my god
i got it he's not answering any
questions that's okay i have no
questions that's right
i'm about to monologue son better make
it quick you only got eight minutes
all right then let me paint you a
picture i'm phillip a successful
periodontist that's become addicted to
diazepam a sedative i take because i'm
junkie scum also for real addiction is a
disease that would be super empathetic
if you hadn't murdered a man what is the
point of this i'll get there so
one day i'm working late when my boss
robert surprises me he found out i was
stealing meds again jackie scum also
again not your fault there's a major
genetic component to addiction he says
he's gonna file a police report
i could lose my license we fight and
something in me just snaps so i grab the
first thing i can find
and i hit him with it you still have no
murder weapon i do now
here's a pic i found on yelp of the
surgical suite six months ago and here's
a shot that our crime scene photographer
took up the same room two weeks after
the murder notice any differences we're
not answering that that's all right i
can just tell you myself the yelp shot
has six of these heavy-looking glass
awards from the brooklyn periodontics
society in the background whereas this
shot only has
five what happened to number six you
murdered robert with him
you lost all control and you bludgeoned
him to death there must have been blood
everywhere but you got lucky
you were in the surgical suite it can be
sterilized you never would have gotten
away with it in your carpeted office
that's not what happened don't say
anything more
and your office manager would have heard
all of the screaming but she was at her
grandson's play
lucky again you're wrong you put
robert's body into a wheelchair and
shoved it in the elevator it's a miracle
there wasn't blood everywhere that's not
true
now you're in the garage with a corpse
you panicked and left your phone in your
office
and you don't have your car keys but
roberts are in his pocket so you put him
in his car
and you take off no you can't believe
what you've done no you're flustered you
have no gps so you just start driving no
phil next thing you know you're in the
pine barrens and it hits you your
uncle's cabin he has a place there
you're the luckiest son of a woman
yes it was you got lucky at every turn
no i knew exactly where i was driving i
left my phone in the office on purpose i
was in a surgical suite by design and i
didn't use some glass award that any
idiot would clearly see was missing
i made a rod out of a special dental
polymer killed him with it and melted it
back down
it's already in a patient's mouth son
oh damn oh damn oh
damn and that is 3-0 dams
oh damn
you